hey guys it's peter brown with a
gamespot news update well it's official
Heidi okajima's name and the logo for
Kojima Productions will not be on the
final cover art for Metal Gear Solid 5
the phantom pain new and seemingly final
versions of the games box art have
stripped away the Kojima logo and the
line de Okajima game this comes just
days after ohtsuka Akio the Japanese
voice actor for snake claim that Kojima
Productions had been disbanded now that
the game is nearly complete this is not
the first time konami has removed the
longtime Metal Gear director's name from
his games back in March the publisher
deleted Kojima Productions branding from
the silent Hills PT website before
announcing that the reboot project had
been cancelled altogether Konami also
wiped kojima's branding from official
artwork and marketing material from
metal gear solid 5 ground zeroes and the
phantom pain and Kojima Productions has
been renamed to konami Studios Los
Angeles but until now the Phantom Pain's
box art had remained untouched back in
March a source close to Kojima
Productions told us that Kojima would
leave the studio once the phantom pain
was complete so assuming this is the
last metal gear game we're going to get
from hideo kojima how do you feel about
the series moving forward if Konami
continues let us know in the comments
below in stay tuned to gamespot com for
all your gaming news
you